[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIE WONG: So
thank you for taking
the time to come visit
Google, and we're all just
going to kick off with
that you're returning
from the first film,
"Bad Moms," and Christmas
is approaching in this film.
So where do we find
each of your characters?
KRISTEN BELL: Oh, I'll start.
Well, Kiki has much repaired
her relationship with Kent.
I'll say that.
She stood up for herself,
which a lot of times,
when you stand up for
yourself, you sort of
set new boundaries
and new dynamics
in your life, which she's done.
Kent helps out a lot at home.
He is no longer a neverhard,
if you know what I mean.
So she has a thriving
sex life, and she's still
friends with both these girls.
But I think as life ebbs and
flows, you go through waves,
where the moms felt like they
took a part of their life back.
But Christmas and the
holidays are approaching,
and they feel like it's
just slipping away,
all that control.
That's where--
MILA KUNIS: God, I love it.
So good.
Amy?
Where's Amy?
So she is in a relationship--
spoiler alert-- with Jay.
Yeah, Jessie.
That's his name.
And that's right.
Jay Hernandez, slash Jessie--
and is in a very happy
place in her life.
She has filed for divorce.
Everything's great.
And her mother-- her
mother comes into town
and throws her in for
a loop of spiraling out
of control and feeling like
she's never good enough
and that nothing she
ever does is good enough
and feeling the pressure to
be as perfect as their mother,
while having these
wonderful women
try to help themselves and
her be strong and powerful
and go against the
system of Christmas.
KATHRYN HAHN: Well, I--
MILA KUNIS: You play Carla.
KATHRYN HAHN: --play Carla.
And thank you.
Mimosa.
Most Carla is trying-- you know,
I think from the last movie,
I think is trying a modicum of--
thank you-- some
responsibility in her life.
She has a job now.
I think she works--
she's an esthetician and all
that that entails at a spa.
And so I think
she's trying to have
a little bit of responsibility.
It's just her and
her boy, and then
yeah, Mom walks
in, who I haven't
seen in years and years.
I don't think Christmas
in their family was ever--
MILA KUNIS: Celebrated.
KATHRYN HAHN: --cele--
really, no one really cared.
Yeah, so I think that's the role
you see her in is trying to--
I think she's trying to have
a little bit of responsibility
and trying to enjoy these last
couple of years with her boy
before he goes away
to school or wherever.
Or who is she kidding?
He's never leaving her home.
JULIE WONG: Oh.
Well, this film was directed
by Jon Lucas and Scott
Moore, the duo best known
for "The Hangover" films.
How much were you able to
influence the script this time
around?
MILA KUNIS: Uh, I
would say, yeah, a lot.
It was a really
nice collaboration.
God, I hate the
sound of my voice.
Sorry, guys.
It was all done very quickly
between the time of yes,
let's do a sequel to let's shoot
the sequel to it coming out,
it's probably been
nine months total.
And so the guys had a
short period of time
to write the script in.
I would say, all in all,
a pretty good amount
of influence, as much as they
were willing to listen to me
talk and talk and talk and do
rewrites and notes with them.
But they're so great
and so inclusive,
and I think they wanted it
to be as good, if not better
as the first one,
and so they were
more than willing to sit
down and talk to anybody who
was willing to give them notes.
KATHRYN HAHN: We were so
excited when we heard the--
at least I was-- when I
heard the idea of where
the sequel would be set or what
time of the year, because there
really isn't another
period, where, you know,
moms, in particular, are
so expected to make magic
happen for everybody
else in their lives.
And it's like, you know,
behind the curtain,
she's sweating and miserable.
And then there's
like an innate comedy
timeline of Christmas Eve.
It's like inherently, you
have to try to get to there--
it's a countdown.
So comedy-wise, we knew.
And it's such a
crazy, crazy pressure
for no reason, where
it should just be
this magic time with everybody.
And of course--
JULIE WONG: Yeah,
and it should be fun.
KATHRYN HAHN: And
it should be fun.
And it gets so--
and it's earlier and earlier.
Clearly, I mean it's October.
But it's so clearly
earlier and earlier.
JULIE WONG: I started my
Christmas list already,
and I've started shopping.
I know.
MILA KUNIS: I start now.
I really do.
KRISTEN BELL: It's insane.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah.
MILA KUNIS: But then
by Thanksgiving, I
don't have any Christmas
shopping to do.
KATHRYN HAHN: No,
then you can relax.
MILA KUNIS: I'm done.
JULIE WONG: Well,
your mothers are
played by award-winning Susan
Sarandon, Christine Baranski,
and Cheryl Hines.
Did any of you have a role in
casting your on-screen moms?
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
KRISTEN BELL: Yes.
MILA KUNIS: Yeah.
JULIE WONG: So you were just
like, me think of who I want?
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
JULIE WONG: And they
were, like, yes.
But that's--
MILA KUNIS: And then they
were like, yeah, sure,
write them a letter.
And you're like, OK.
And then you're like,
send And people respond.
It's kind of crazy.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah,
it's kind of crazy.
JULIE WONG: That's so smooth.
KRISTEN BELL: The directors
are very confident,
but also, like,
they're resigned.
They're not like gigantic
personalities that
jump into a room, but
they're confident enough
to know that they take
all advice and all ideas.
And they use the ones they like.
And there's just something
sort of beautiful about that,
so they listened to all
of our Christmas stories,
thought about what we would
want our characters doing,
and then they thought
about how they
would place that into the film.
And I think the same
thing went with the moms.
They were like, who
do you connect to?
Who do you feel like you
would want to work with?
Who are you friendly with?
Who do you think is
wonderful for this?
But they're really,
really collaborative.
JULIE WONG: Yeah, it seems
like it was the perfect cast.
So one of my favorite
lines is delivered
by Christine Baranski.
She says, "You're a mom.
Moms don't enjoy.
They give joy.
That's how being a mom works."
And can you tell us more
about each of their characters
and what we can expect?
MILA KUNIS: They're all--
no, you can go ahead.
KRISTEN BELL: No, [INAUDIBLE].
My mom is played by Cheryl
Hines, who weirdly enough,
has been like a friend of
mine for about a decade.
So I was like, this is weird,
but do you want to play my mom,
and we can just add a weird
line that you had me when you
were, like, 10 or something?
And she was like, sure.
So we already had a very strong
friendship bond going into it,
and we share a similar
sense of humor,
and I sort of idolized her.
And I was so excited
that she said yes.
And the storyline with Kiki--
it pretty much wrote
itself in that, of course,
Kiki has the issues she has,
because she had an overbearing
mother, like an intensely
overbearing mother,
a mother that wore her face
on her sweatshirt often,
and a mother that cuts and
colors her hair exactly
the same, a mother that just
cannot stop living through her
daughter, and how much
pressure Kiki feels,
and how that makes her sort
of neurotic and unable to set
a boundary, because she's
fearful of hurting her mom,
which I've experienced.
And it was wonderful
to be able to work
in a safe, fun environment
with Cheryl, who's
one of the best, also,
improv female comedians we
have out there.
So she, I feel like,
brought a ton to it,
and I was just really
grateful that she said yes.
MILA KUNIS: I had the pleasure
of Christine Baranski, who
came about of me going,
hm, who makes me nervous?
And I was like,
Christine Baranski.
My character in the
first one was constantly
trying to be perfect, and
that was her whole spiral of,
how do I beat the
ideals of perfection?
So the mother that
I get in the movie
is somebody who has
to have everything
be exactly the way the public
would want it to perceive.
So everything has to
visually be great.
Doesn't matter what's
happening behind closed doors,
but you don't air
your dirty laundry,
and everything
has to be perfect,
and the kids have to be happy,
and it has to be the best this,
and everything has to be
perfect and wonderful and great.
And so I was like, who makes
me nervous as a person?
And I literally like,
Christine Baranski
kind of makes me nervous.
And I was like, well,
let's see what happens.
And literally, that's
how it went about.
And then I emailed her
and was like, hey, there's
this little movie we
did called "Bad Moms."
Like I went on a whole thing,
and she was like, yeah, OK.
And that was it.
And I was like, do you
want to read the script?
She's like, no, that's fine.
And then the directors,
Jon and Scott, met with her
and pitched her the idea
of this character that's
a very overbearing mother.
And all the moms,
ultimately, have
a reason as to why they
are the way that they are,
which explains why our
characters became the way they
became, which is very
reminiscent of you are who
your parents are, whether
your parents were consciously
driving you, and you
fought against it,
and you became a rebel,
or you went into it
and became Mark Zuckerberg.
Like whatever version of
that you became, it is true.
You are what your parents are.
And so in this
case, I think this
gives an explanation as to
why we, as mothers, are so
constantly fighting
for perfection.
KRISTEN BELL: And it also--
I think what they did a
great job of in this movie
is they give the moms enough
behind the curtain time
and peel away the onion
time, where it does sort
of resonate that,
like, guys, everybody's
doing the best they can
with what they've got.
JULIE WONG: Yeah.
KRISTEN BELL: You know?
And that rings true
for our characters,
but it also, throughout
the course of the movie,
you see, yeah, your
mom is so annoying,
but she's doing the best
she can with what she got.
MILA KUNIS: And it explains why.
Like you no longer
resent your parents.
KRISTEN BELL: Oh, yeah.
MILA KUNIS: And let
me take that back.
I meant Larry Page,
not Mark Zuckerberg.
OK, guys?
My bad.
I apologize.
I also mean Eric Schmidt.
We can go down the list.
JULIE WONG: That's OK.
We're all friends.
MILA KUNIS: I didn't mean Zuck.
Sorry go on.
KATHRYN HAHN: I got to get on
this bob game, too, you guys.
Your hair looks so
awesome, both of yours.
I feel like I'm the odd odd
woman out with this long hair.
MILA KUNIS: Fuck the hair, guys.
JULIE WONG: [INAUDIBLE]
for your scenes.
KATHRYN HAHN: Right.
JULIE WONG: Yeah.
KATHRYN HAHN: Susan
Sarandon, you guys.
JULIE WONG: I know.
KATHRYN HAHN: It's nutso.
I mean, I was so excited.
And similarly, I was like, who--
there's only one person
in the world that
would make Carla feel small,
and that would be her mother.
And then I was so excited at
the thought of it being Susan,
and I, yeah, wrote her as well.
MILA KUNIS: You wanted
Susan Sarandon very early
[INAUDIBLE].
KATHRYN HAHN: I did.
I was like, oh, my god.
I just knew it.
And then even just being in a
scene with her would be very--
it would take me a second,
because it would be all those
movies would--
it was like, "Thelma and
Louise," "Dead Man Walking,"
"Rocky Horror Picture Show."
So it's like hard to refocus,
because she's such a goddess.
They all are.
We really lucked out
with these women.
And so yeah, I think in their
dynamic, Carla and her mom,
it's more--
I think they were more,
like, kind of siblings
than mother-daughter.
You know what I mean?
There was not a
lot of boundaries.
JULIE WONG: Friendship.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah, exactly.
JULIE WONG: Well,
we were thinking
about how you
celebrate the holidays,
since it is a holiday film.
Can you share what some of
your favorite traditions are
and if you are sharing
this with your children?
KATHRYN HAHN: Oh, my god.
Well, when I grew up, we used
to have to sing "Happy Birthday
Baby Jesus" on Christmas Eve.
I'm not kidding you.
My mom would get a cake, and we
would be like, happy birthday.
And I had so many questions.
Like, how many candles?
It was so confusing.
I have not passed that on.
JULIE WONG: A lot of candles.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah, I
have not passed that on,
but that was something
we had to do.
At least sing "Happy
Birthday Baby Jesus.
Like, [SINGING] happy
birthday, Baby Jesus.
And we were all like--
just did it.
So weird.
MILA KUNIS: What kind of cake?
KATHRYN HAHN: Baskin
Robbins, Santa Claus cake.
So it was confusing on a whole--
a lot of levels.
JULIE WONG: Even better.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah.
MILA KUNIS: I got
nothing, you guys.
JULIE WONG: I don't know
that we can top that.
MILA KUNIS: Tradition
that I've passed down--
I don't really have--
none.
I mean, no, because you
know, I'm Jewish, you guys.
So not to be like,
rah-rah, don't really
celebrate Christmas.
But sorry.
I also grew up in
communist Russia,
where you don't really
celebrate Christmas.
But I do now, so yay.
I think we're creating
traditions is the best
way that I can explain it.
So our kid is in--
she's-- how do I explain this?
She's having a
hard time grasping
why a man is coming into
our house through a chimney.
So spoiler alert-- we're not
teaching her about Santa Claus.
We're not not
teaching her, but we
try to explain to
her that there's
a man that's coming
into the house,
and she was like, [GASPS], why?
KRISTEN BELL: That's so
weird, like one night a year,
breaking and entering is OK.
MILA KUNIS: But if you kid
believes in it, it's great.
KATHRYN HAHN: [INAUDIBLE].
KRISTEN BELL: Oh, so he's got
a bunch of exotics on the roof.
He's in a jumpsuit and combat
boots, but don't worry.
MILA KUNIS: Did
your kids buy it?
Because mine's not buying it.
She's like, I don't get it.
KRISTEN BELL: One of them
does, one of them doesn't.
JULIE WONG: [INAUDIBLE]
Harley or Jay Hernandez,
maybe that would be OK.
MILA KUNIS: Not for my daughter.
KRISTEN BELL: It's
scary, though, because I
try to be so honest
about everything else.
And even like during
Easter, I was like, bunny--
too far.
That's too far.
I was like, we play a game,
where we pretend and imagine
this giant bunny brings
us an Easter basket,
but Mommy went to the store
and got this for you. .
But around Christmas,
everyone talks about it,
and you don't ever want to say
it in front of another kid,
because you don't want to insult
another parent and take over.
That's their domain.
But I'm having a hard time
lying to them about it.
MILA KUNIS: I tried lying.
I'm really trying.
KRISTEN BELL: Oh, so like--
MILA KUNIS: I'm like, see,
that's totally awesome.
She's like, I don't get it.
JULIE WONG: [INAUDIBLE],,
tooth fairy.
You name it.
[INAUDIBLE]
KRISTEN BELL: Yeah, but
also, so when they find out,
they're going to go, what else
have you lied to me about?
KATHRYN HAHN: Well,
that's what's confusing.
It's when your kids--
KRISTEN BELL: And then
that's like, shit, I
shouldn't have lied.
You're right.
I've lost it.
KATHRYN HAHN: It's when your
kids have questions about God,
but then you're, like,
but with definitively,
but there's a tooth fairy.
But you're like, some
people believe this.
It gets confusing.
KRISTEN BELL: I was babysitting
yesterday an extra kid
at my house.
Here is some of the
questions that I
fielded throughout the day.
Is Santa Claus real?
And I couldn't say anything
in front of the other kid.
Who made dogs?
Why is the earth?
Literally, I was like-- no,
no, that was the question.
And they're just, like,
painting, and they're like,
who made dogs?
Why is the earth?
And I was like, oh, my
god, where's my husband?
I can't--
JULIE WONG: Sounds like
an awesome play date.
We'll have to come over.
KRISTEN BELL: I was like,
I'm Kiki in real life.
It's so sad.
MILA KUNIS: You're
like, it's a planet.
JULIE WONG: Well,
you're all working moms,
and the pressures of
being a perfect parent
is something that we
can all relate to.
So is there a secret to
your work life integration?
And then what do
you do to recharge?
KATHRYN HAHN: Well, I
love my girlfriends,
like, my tribe of other
mamas and humans that I love
and that we share the same
kind of phil-- you know.
You just find your group.
And I cherish that.
And then I think the
balance is really hard.
It's hard.
JULIE WONG: Oh, yeah.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah.
JULIE WONG: I try not to say
balance anymore, because--
KATHRYN HAHN: You can't.
JULIE WONG: --I don't
believe that balance exists.
KATHRYN HAHN: No.
It doesn't.
It's just-- it is really like--
I've always thought,
like, it really does suck
that biologically, our chief
money-making years are lined up
with our fertility.
It just blows.
You know what I mean?
It's just what it is, but
it really sucks for us.
Anyway, I'm going to
have some more mimosa.
JULIE WONG: Let's
drink some more
and just make the
most out of it.
KATHRYN HAHN: To women.
JULIE WONG: Any secrets to
just recharging, signing off?
KRISTEN BELL: I mean,
self-care is huge.
I think, like, just knowing
when you're feeling frustrated
and knowing when you need to
call a girlfriend or when you
need to even just tag
team with your-- like we,
in our household,
we'll be like--
I'll be like, I've
got to switch kids.
I don't want this one anymore.
JULIE WONG: Oh, yeah.
KRISTEN BELL: I'm not
doing this one right now,
because one of them
will be partic--
I'm not-- I don't want--
I want to switch.
And then he's like, got it.
Totally, totally.
And then we switch, because
sometimes you just need
to know when you're
getting higher,
your thermometer
is getting higher.
And whether that goes
for, like, oh, it's
been four months since
I've like a girls' dinner.
I'm going to do that.
Any amount of self-care,
and never ever, ever, ever,
beating yourself up
for needing self-care--
I used to do that all the time.
And I was like, no, I should
be of service to my family.
And I was like, no, I can get a
manicure once every six months.
Like, that's OK.
Do you know what I mean?
And not killing myself
for it, and also,
surrendering to the fact
that there is no balance.
It is only just have a mantra.
Like just be where you are.
Like when I'm at home,
I focus on my family.
When I'm at work, I
focus on work and scroll
through pictures of my family.
But you just have
to be where you are.
It's really just mindfulness.
Like there's no-- the
balance is such a sad joke.
JULIE WONG: Yeah.
KRISTEN BELL: You know?
MILA KUNIS: I mean I can just
talk for the sake of talking,
but I actually have--
yeah, everything that
you said, I agree with.
There's no balance.
But I also don't want it
to be like a woman thing.
There's just no balance if
you're a working parent.
There is no balance.
It doesn't matter if
you're a man or woman.
I am incredibly fortunate,
and I've said this before,
and I'll say it again.
I do have an amazing
partner in life.
I do-- who just-- yeah.
Who?
That's right.
Who, you guys?
Who my partner?
He's fucking awesome.
And I'm not going to shit
on him, because he's great.
And guess who was
home with the kids
today at 5:00 in the morning
when I was getting ready.
He was.
He was awesome.
And you know, I had to
go away for five months
to shoot something, and he
took the time off from work.
He was like-- you know,
we travel as a tribe,
as I know you do.
Where one goes, the other
one follows with the kids.
And for five months, he
was on a flip schedule.
So we were in Europe, so
he would work from 9:00 PM
to, like, 5:00 in
the morning, and then
be with the kids all day.
Never once did he complain,
and all the time, he would go,
you know, I'm so blessed
that I get to spend
this much time with the kids.
And it's the most
great-- like it's--
you take it for granted
having a partner,
whether it's hired help or a
husband or a wife or whatever.
Anyone that allows
you to just be like,
I can't do this
anymore, to your point,
don't take them for granted.
Don't, because I think it's
the one thing that I sometimes
forget to do is just
simply say thank you,
because as much as I'm
like, I'm about to explode.
I need to go and,
like, lock myself up
in the closet for a minute,
he's like, babe, you got this.
Go.
And I'm like, OK,
OK, I got this.
But you just-- I think
that we should just
be grateful for whatever
help it is that you're
able to conceive, whether it's
your friends, your girlfriends,
your village, your
mom, your dad.
KRISTEN BELL: Don't feel
guilty for relying on help.
MILA KUNIS: No.
Never feel guilty about it.
And that's the one thing
that I think both of you
helped me with two years ago,
because I had the hardest time
asking for help two years ago.
When I did "Bad
Moms," the first one
was the first time I went back
to work after having kids,
and I literally was like--
you know, as Daniel Tagger says,
when you're feeling frustrated,
step back and ask
for help, y'all.
Fucking step back
and ask for help.
It's OK.
And it took me forever
to be OK with it.
And you and you were the
biggest champions of that,
so I thank you.
It's true.
JULIE WONG: Well, cheers for our
girlfriends and our partners.
We'll go ahead and
start taking questions,
if you want to line up.
And I guess to wrap up,
yeah, where would each of you
like to see your characters
go, if there was a third film?
MILA KUNIS: To Hawaii.
KRISTEN BELL: On vacation.
KATHRYN HAHN: A destination.
JULIE WONG: Actually,
vacation takes a lot of work.
MILA KUNIS: That's the
bad moms plan a vacation.
JULIE WONG: I feel you.
KRISTEN BELL: Just planning
a family vacation--
JULIE WONG: Packing,
having everything
you need on the plane ride.
MILA KUNIS: Favorite
thing in the world.
JULIE WONG: I don't
know [INAUDIBLE]..
MILA KUNIS: [INAUDIBLE]
forgot to lock up our kids
in their car seats once.
JULIE WONG: Oh,
yeah, car seats--
MILA KUNIS: Drop them in.
JULIE WONG: --on that
airplane in the car
that you have to run.
Yeah, we could go on and on.
Great, so we'll go ahead and
start with the first question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for
coming to Google.
It's great to see all of you.
My question is, how was working
on this set of "Bad Moms"
different than other sets
you worked on in the past?
KATHRYN HAHN: Well,
it's a Christmas movie,
and we shot it in
Atlanta in May and June.
So that was relaxing.
Pools of sweat in places I
didn't know could gather.
KRISTEN BELL: I
think we were also
kind of like, whereas the last
movie, we had a lot of peers,
and like we were all very
friendly, this movie,
we were all sort of,
like, in awe of the things
that Christine and Susan and
Cheryl were sort of bringing.
And we felt-- I feel like
I felt a little bit more
like a fan girl on
this, not that I'm not
in love with the other
women that we worked with.
But this just felt a
little bit more like--
I don't know, like, why
are they doing our movie?
This is so exciting.
You know?
JULIE WONG: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'll second that.
Thank you so much for
coming to Google today.
One of my favorite parts of the
first movie, which was amazing,
but the very end,
where each of you
were interviewed with
your moms, I thought
was incredibly touching
and so transparent
of you, especially
in the public light,
to have your moms be there.
So with your new stage
moms in the second one,
did your moms get to meet
any of your screen moms?
MILA KUNIS: No.
KATHRYN HAHN: My mom did.
She happened to be there while
we were doing a gallery shoot,
so remember, we were
doing the publicity,
and so she got to meet her,
which was very, very exciting.
Yeah.
But those first
interviews were so dear.
And remember-- do you
remember they ended up
being incredible interviewers?
Jon and Scott, our
directors and writers,
actually did the interviews
for all of us as couple--
the mothers and daughters,
and it was-- they
were pretty revealing.
It got real deep in there.
MILA KUNIS: Very
Barbara Walters.
KATHRYN HAHN: It was.
JULIE WONG: Oh, yeah.
It was really well done.
MILA KUNIS: My mom has not
met Christine Baranski,
but my mom's five
feet on a good day.
Like if she stands
up really tall,
she's maybe five feet tall.
And she's tiny.
She's just a tiny little
thing, because [INAUDIBLE]
tall and beautifully.
My mom's like, that's
what I imagine myself as.
She was like, that's how I feel.
It's very cute,
so they will meet.
Yeah, for sure.
They're both awesome.
Thank you.
JULIE WONG: I think we
have one last question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thank you, first off,
for doing the movie,
giving us a reason
to go get drunk
and get all the weird
kind of awkward moms
from preschool together
and represent body moms.
Thank you.
KRISTEN BELL: Get some, girl.
AUDIENCE: Neurotic,
really organized.
I loved it.
I was just curious
which pieces really
resonated the most with you.
Like, if you could have
chosen the characters,
would you have
chosen the character
that you got assigned to?
MILA KUNIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MILA KUNIS: Without a-- yes.
Yes.
I can go on a very
lengthy explanation
as to why, but with the first
"Bad Moms," that was me.
I literally was like,
I had so much pressure
that I put on myself, not
anybody else, of everything
has to be perfect for
my kid, for my life.
Everything-- I need to organize.
I need to figure this out.
I literally was going
crazy, because I
was like, what's a shower?
Like I forgot to take care
of myself so much so that I--
it was the most perfect therapy
session was doing this movie.
Both of these films have been
like giant therapies for me.
KATHRYN HAHN: I'd
say Carla is more
my spirit animal, like I wish.
AUDIENCE: That's
actually reassuring.
KATHRYN HAHN: Yeah, I wish.
JULIE WONG: I think we all wish.
KATHRYN HAHN: We got
a little inner inner.
JULIE WONG: Oh, yeah.
We all have some of her in us.
KRISTEN BELL: When
I first read--
Mila had this script,
and she called me,
and she was like,
read this script.
You should do this with me.
And I read it, and I was like--
MILA KUNIS: Bullied her.
KRISTEN BELL: --this is so good.
And I was like, maybe I
should play the bitchy one.
Like I wanted to play
Chris-- remember this?
I want to play Christina's role.
I was like, she's
so funny, and that
would be so cool, because
I could be super bitchy.
And she's like, no,
no, no, you're Kiki.
You're Kiki.
That's it.
And I was like, OK, cool.
And then I realized,
that's such a Kiki thing
to do to be like, ooh,
maybe I can play the vixen.
And everyone would be like,
no, that's not your essence.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thanks for being
true to yourselves.
JULIE WONG: Well, in closing,
on behalf of all the bad moms
at Google, I want to
thank you for portraying
the realities of being a
mom and giving us a reason
to have a moms' night out.
So be sure to watch "A
Bad Moms Christmas" out
in theaters on November 1st.
KATHRYN HAHN: I want a
micro kitchen 400 feet
from where I am at all times.
That's the best idea.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE WONG: I'm
learning on the loo.
KATHRYN HAHN: I'm obsessed.
JULIE WONG: Thank you so much.